will this extra money make it a world of
difference for several families
struggling to make ends meet in our area
spoke to a single father who says the
money came just when he couldn't decide
whether to pay the rent or get
everything on his grocery list
for the first time in a long time duane
walker and his nine-year-old son trason
are not putting off back to school
shopping he is thankful for the child's
tax credit probably would have been
able to buy a really big notebook i
wouldn't have to get another notebook
it's the simple things like an extra
notebook that feels like a luxury item
for the walker family
it's not a lot of room for much extra
it comes right up to the tip of the
glass every time
but luckily we ain't spilling walker is
a single dad who works as a driver
but it's still not enough to pay all the
bills
sometimes he can't get everything on his
grocery list
the things that i would normally buy i
didn't have enough for and so i had to
start putting things back individually
i happened to be on the phone with
walker just when he received his 250
dollars
the sense of relief was evident i was
hustling hard the last week i was at the
line my head was just above water
and yeah that was my life raft you know
came floating wrong and just said hey
here you go
he says although bills are consistent
money isn't
and now he has some extra security
is one of the greatest comforts you can
have and it's all for that i'm secure
for now
victoria saha 8 news now
many of you reached out to us saying
that you have not received the tax
credit
may take a few days actually to hit your
bank account it's rolling out if you
got your stimulus checked previously
through the mail then that's going to be
how you will receive
the tax credit for children